FOR MONDAY JANUARY THIRD TWENTY
TWENTY TWO IS HEREBY CALLED
ORDER. PLEASE BE ADVISED THE
AUDIO VIDEO RECORDINGS BEING
MADE TODAY'S PROCEEDINGS AND IS
ALSO BEING TELEVISED. MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC ATTENDED SERMONS WERE
MASK AT ALL TIMES. ATTENDEES
MUST ALSO REFRAIN FROM CONDUCT
THAT DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR
OTHERWISE IMPEDES THE ORDERLY
CONDUCT OF THIS RULES COMMITTEE
HEARING. VIOLATIONS OF THESE
RULES WERE SUBJECTED VISUAL TO
REMOVAL OR OTHER ENFORCEMENT
PROCESS MR SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL COOLEY HERE CUNNINGHAM
HERE SENATE. BONTA FLORA YOUR
GIPSON HERE WE MAIENSCHEIN.
MATHIS RAMOS RUBIO. REPERTOIRE
EVERCORE WE HAVE A QUORUM WE
HAVE A CONSENT AGENDA- IS OUR
MOTION ON THE CONSENT AGENDA.
MOVED BY MISTER GIPSON SECONDED
BY MR FOR A- MR SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. COOLEY HI COOLEY
AYE CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I.
BENNETT BENNETT HI BONTA FLORA
FLORA I GIPSON. GIPSON HIGHLY
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MATHIS MATHIS HIERONYMUS. RUBIO
RUBIO HI THE ABUJA MOTION PASSES
TO MOTIONS PASSED- WE LOOK
FORWARD TO BEING JOINED THIS
YEAR BY SOME OF OUR COLLEAGUES
OR UNAVAILABLE TODAY DUE TO
ILLNESS AND A SUMMER BONTA JOINS
US ON THIS COMMITTEE AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO SERVING WITH HER AS
WELL. THIS RULES WHAT IS
ADJOURNED.